guten tag
guten tag wie kann ich ihnen helfen
[Musik]
was kann ich für sie tun
ich brauche schinken bitte
ich hätte gern schinken bitte
ich möchte schinken bitte
nehmen sie ein
stück schinken oder nehmen sie den
schinken geschnitten
nehmen sie einen gang
stück schinken oder nehmen sie den
schinken geschnitten
geschnitten bitte
wieviel 200 gramm
nein das ist zu viel
bitte 100 gramm schinken und auch noch
100 gramm speck
hier bitte ist das alles
wir haben heute abend besuch können sie
mir etwas empfehlen
wir haben ein gutes stück fleisch im
sonderangebot es kostet 20 prozent
weniger
wir haben ein gutes
fleisch im sonderangebot es kostet 20
prozent weniger
gut das nehme ich
für wie viele personen kochen sie
kochen sie
vier erwachsene und ein kind
hier bitte darf es sonst noch etwas sein
nein danke das ist alles
das macht 56 franken bitte
bezahlen sie bei
der mieter karte
bezahlen sie bar
mit der karte
mit karte bitte
vielen dank hier noch ihre quittung
kann ich bitte noch einen plastiksack
haben
ja sicher
hier bitte
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen tag und
ein gutes abendessen mit ihrem besuch
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
und ein gutes abendessen mit ihrem
besuch
vielen dank auf wiedersehen vielen dank
auf wiedersehen
wohl biete einen einkaufswagen
wohl biete einen einkaufswagen daniel
oh ich habe keinen
münster bei
ich habe
hast du einen franken damit ich den
wagen holen kann
ja hier
was kaufen wir alles ein
ich habe eine einkaufsliste gemacht
gehen wir zuerst zur früchte und
gemüseabteilung
also wir brauchen bananen äpfel und
orangen
hier bitte
daniel nicht nur einen apfel eine banane
und eine orange
wir brauchen davon je circa 1 kilo
[Musik]
oh ja ich hole mehr
oh ja ich hole mir
jetzt brauchen wir noch einen broccoli
je eine rote gelbe und grüne paprika
zwiebeln und kartoffeln
jetzt brauchen wir noch einen brokkoli
je eine rote gelbe und grüne paprika
zwiebeln und kartoffeln
eine zwiebel und eine kartoffel
dom cobb
natürlich nicht
dummkopf
nimmt ca
zwiebeln und ein kilogramm kartoffeln
nimmt circa fünf zwiebeln und ein
kilogramm kartoffeln
es gibt schon einen abgepackten sack
kartoffeln
schau doch es gibt schon einen
abgepackten sack kartoffeln
los gehen wir weiter
ich möchte ein neues rezept für kekse
ausprobieren
wir brauchen dazu 5 500 gramm mehl 500
gramm zucker und eine tafel schokolade
guten tag
guten tag wie kann ich ihnen
üblich seien
ich sein
ich habe heute diesem k
gekauft
[Musik]
ich habe heute die
ein käse gekauft
er ist aber schon über dem verfallsdatum
das sollte nicht passieren
das tut uns leid haben sie noch die
quittung
ja hier vielen dank
hier ist das geld
vielen dank
entschuldigen sie die umstände
kein
leben
auf wiedersehen
kein
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare
wir werden sie beantworten
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare wir werden sie
beantworten
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal